Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a Dashlane.
Cada día pasamos más tiempo en internet
y, ¿sabéis qué? Con el nivel extra de seguridad
que proporciona Dashlane, se navega más tranquilo.
Dashlane es la herramienta todo en uno para
gestionar tu identidad digital. No solo te
recordará toda tu información de pago y
tus contraseñas sino que también te ayudará
a generar nuevas contraseñas seguras sin
que te rompas la cabeza.
Dashlane funciona con todo tipo de dispositivos
y sistemas: Mac, Windows, Android, en Safari,
en Chrome, …
Además también te proporciona el monitoreo
de la dark web, escaneando la web en busca
de datos personales filtrados o robados, alertándote
al instante en caso de que tus datos personales
se encuentren donde no deben.
Haz tu vida más sencilla y ve a dashlane.com/visualpolitikes
para usar Dashlane de forma totalmente gratuita
en tu primer dispositivo, y si decides irte
a la versión premium usa nuestro código
"visualpolitikes" para tener un 10% de descuento.
(Pedro Castillo, candidato de Perú Libre,
un partido de izquierda marxista ganó en
segunda vuelta las elecciones presidenciales
del 2021. Durante la campaña este candidato
planteó la posibilidad de nacionalizar empresas,
terminar con el modelo de pensiones de capitalización,
castigar las importaciones y suspender acuerdos
de libre comercio, entre otras muchas cuestiones.)
¿Cómo demonios Pedro Castillo ha ganado
las elecciones? ¿Cómo han podido los peruanos
votar por un líder como este? Porque más
allá de si hubo o no irregularidades con
alguna papeleta lo cierto es que Castillo
cosechó un enorme apoyo popular.
La respuesta más fácil sería decir que
ha ganado porque Keiko Fujimori era muy mal
candidata o por la pandemia. Al fin y al cabo…la
gestión de la pandemia en Perú fue una de
las peores del mundo. Con los peores registros
en términos de muertes por millón y una
de las recesiones económicas más grandes.
Sin embargo, hay más, mucho más, y eso es
precisamente lo que queremos ver en este vídeo.
¿Cómo es posible que el Perú, una de las
rockstar de Latinoamérica durante las últimas
2 décadas haya decidido votar ahora por un
presidente que habla de marxismo, nacionalizaciones
y de nuevo, otra vez en latinoamérica, de
la sustitución de importaciones?
Es decir, un presidente que parece querer
volver a echarse en brazos del plan, la estrategia,
la política que tantas veces ha malogrado
a los países de latinoamérica. Y que, de
forma más incomprensible que la mezcla de
arenques con chocolate vuelve una y otra y
otra vez a la primera plana política de la
región.
[Pero, ¿qué demonios pasa? ¿Qué en Latinoamérica
no quieren salir de pobres? Pero, ¿Por qué
no copian lo que funciona? Si es que basta
con copiar.]
Queridos amigos, amigas de VisualPolitik,
¿Qué se esconde tras la victoria de Pedro
Castillo?
Atentos.
(CUANDO SE MALOGRÓ EL PERÚ)
En 2016 publicamos este vídeo: Perú, ¿Una
nueva potencia en Latinoamérica?. Fue uno
de los primeros vídeos que hicimos sobre
esta región del mundo.
Y, ¿sabéis qué? En aquel momento amigos,
todo apuntaba a que el país andino, pacífico
y amazónico [para que luego no os quejéis
los que nos veis desde Perú] iba a comerse
el mundo.
Los números eran tan buenos que parecía
casi imposible que las cosas no salieran bien.
¿Queréis alguna prueba? Pues.. Tomad nota:
desde el año 2000 el país había registrado
la segunda mayor tasa de crecimiento económico
de toda latinoamérica, desde ese mismo año
la inversión anual se había multiplicado
por 5 y las cuentas del gobierno se situaban
entre las más saneadas de todo el planeta.
Hablamos de una evolución económica que
había logrado que la pobreza se redujera
a menos de la mitad, pasando de niveles por
encima del 50% a poco más del 20, en apenas
15 años.
(Con semejantes datos el Perú parecía preparado
para meterse de lleno en la champions de los
países más prósperos. Con las cuentas públicas
saneadas, muchas nuevas empresas brotando
por todo el país, un crecimiento medio por
encima del 5%, la inflación controlada y
los capitales extranjeros llegando a raudales,
todo parecía listo para que la economía
nacional rivalizara con el despegue de las
economías asiáticas más pujantes.)
Ojo, es que Perú se ha convertido, incluso,
en uno de los países con más acuerdos de
libre comercio de todo el mundo. Acuerdos
y que le dan vía libre a todas las grandes
economías del mundo: Estados Unidos, China,
la Unión Europea, Japón, Corea del Sur,
el Reino Unido, Canadá, o Australia entre
otros muchos. En total Perú tiene acuerdos
de libre comercio con más del 80% de la economía
mundial.
Una política que le permitió al país multiplicar
casi por 6 sus exportaciones entre el 2000
y el 2019. Lo que, evidentemente, supuso una
enorme y creciente entrada de divisas extranjeras.
Así que con semejante panorama, la pregunta
que estoy convencido muchos os estáis haciendo
es, ¿Qué demonios pasó para que de repente
las cosas se torcieran tanto en el Perú?
Pues, un momento, porque lo cierto es que
toda esta prosperidad empezó a encallarse
en el año 2016. Y poco a poco lo que iba
viento en popa y a toda vela, pues empezó
a ir más y más despacio..
Por ejemplo, si entre el 2005 y el 2009 el
país promedió un crecimiento del 6,5% anual,
entre el 2010 y el 2014 fue del 5,8% y entre
el 2015 y el 2019 de apenas el 3,2%. Un nivel
insuficiente, por ejemplo, para seguir reduciendo
la pobreza.
Y de hecho, tras más de 20 años de fuerte
crecimiento, el 70% de la población peruana
no había sido capaz de pasar de nivel, las
infraestructuras a todos los niveles seguían
siendo calamitosas y la prosperidad percibida
parecía ir a menos.
Y luego, para colmo, llegó el coronavirus.
Que fue tal y como hemos comentado fue algo
así como la gota que colmó el vaso.
Y, amigos, llegados a este punto, sé perfectamente
cuál es la pregunta que os estáis haciendo…
Pero, Couto, ¿Qué demonios pasó en Perú?
¿Cómo logró un candidato como Castillo
hacerse con la mayoría popular?
Pues…. Atentos.
(LA DESLEALTAD INSTITUCIONAL)
Podríamos hablar del 2000, del 2005, del
2011 o prácticamente de cualquiera de los
últimos años del Perú y la historia no
cambiaría demasiado. Eso sí, con un matiz:
las cosas han ido a peor.
Y 2016 fue algo así como el disparo de salida
para una especie de una macabra cuenta atras
hacia la autodestrucción.
[Vale, no quiero ser exagerado]. Dejémoslo
en que en ese año 2016 dio comienzo una nueva
turbulenta etapa en lo político, en lo social
e incluso en lo económico.
Y es que, en ese año hubo elecciones y el
resultado no pudo ser más complejo. En las
presidenciales Pedro Pablo Kuczynski se hizo
con la victoria en segunda vuelta por poco
más de 40.000 votos frente a Keiko Fujimori.
Sin embargo, en las legislativas el resultado
fue muy diferente. Fuerza Popular, el partido
de Keiko se hizo con 73 de los 130 escaños.
Esto es con más de la mitad de los escaños
mientras que PPK el partido del presidente
apenas logró 18.
Y ahí fue cuando las cosas empezaron a ir
de mal en peor. Por un lado, frente a cualquier
ápice de responsabilidad política, Fuerza
Popular decidió ir con todo contra el gobierno
de Kuczynski. El parlamento se convirtió
así en un terreno hostil para el propio gobierno…
Lo que, como os podéis imaginar, supuso frenar
muchos de los cambios que el gobierno quería
liderar y para colmo por momentos el acoso
fue muy duro.
¿Responsabilidad política? ¿El interés
del Perú primero? ¡Ja!
Claro que, un momento, porque eso iba a ser
tan solo el comienzo.
Al poco tiempo, una bomba política iba a
poner patas arriba al país: en diciembre
de ese mismo año 2016 la Unidad Anticorrupción
de la Fiscalía General de Perú ordenó investigar
la posible relación de Kuczynski con la constructora
brasileña Odebrecht.
Sí, esa empresa que prácticamente compró
a todos los políticos de Latinoamérica.
(Pero ahí no iba a quedar todo. Un año después
de que la fiscalía comenzara sus pesquisas,
la propia Comisión Lava Jato del Congreso
peruano mostró pruebas de la relación entre
Kuczynski y la constructora brasileña cuando
el primero era ministro de finanzas.
Según estas informaciones, una empresa propiedad
de Kuczynski y afincada en Miami, Westfield
recibió varios contratos de Odebrecht poco
tiempo después de que esta constructora recibiera
en 2004 la garantía de que el estado peruano
asumiría los riesgos económicos derivados
del proyecto energético y de regadío de
los Olmos, en el departamento de Lambayeque.
Hablamos de una garantía de casi 500 millones
de dólares para una iniciativa privada.)
Es decir, simplificando, si la empresa ganaba
dinero con el proyecto de los olmos, engordaría
su beneficio. Si la cosa resultaba en pérdidas
entonces pagaba el gobierno peruano. Bueno.
así es como hacía negocios Odebrecht.
El caso es que a partir de ese momento comenzó
toda una guerra política. El 15 de diciembre
de 2017 el Congreso del Perú admitió a trámite
un primer pedido de vacancia presidencial.
La vacancia es una figura por la que el legislativo
peruano puede destituir al mandatario invocando
a su incapacidad moral o física. Vamos que con la vacancia el Congreso, pues, puede despedir al Presidente, le puede mandar a hacer puñetas.
(La cosa no salió adelante, entre otras cosas
porque Kuczynski pacto con el hermano de Keiko
Fujimori, Kenji Fujimori su apoyo el de algunos
congresistas más a cambio de indultar a su
padre, Alberto Fujimori. Cosa que Kuczynski
hizo apenas unos días después.
Una decisión que provocó protestas masivas
y la renuncia de 3 ministros. Pero la cosa
no se quedó ahí. Con más pruebas, el congreso
intentó un nuevo proceso de vacancia y esta
vez aparecieron unos vídeos de Kenji Fujimori
intentando sobornar a congresistas con acceso
a obras públicas a cambio de votar en contra
de deponer al presidente.)
Kuczynski, un líder que había llegado con
un discurso de cambio, un mensaje e ideas
frescas que le hicieron incluso ganarse uno
de los premios VisualPolitik, terminó dimitiendo
el 21 de marzo de 2018.
Lo peor, lo peor es que el gobierno de Kuczynski
inició una campaña masiva que luego continuó
su sucesor Martín Vizcarra acusando al congreso
de perpetrar un Golpe de Estado a pesar de
que la vacancia es una figura plenamente constitucional.
Vizcarra que por cierto luego fue vancado
también por acusaciones de corrupción y
de nuevo en medio de enormes protestas. En
total 4 presidentes en una legislatura.
Y, diréis, ¿Cuál es el problema?
Pues,veréis: Por un lado este tipo de comportamientos
genera un enorme descrédito y desconfianza
hacia las instituciones, tanto entre los propios
peruanos como entre los inversores extranjeros.
Por otro lado, no seamos ingenuos, esta crisis
política nos mostró las motivaciones reales
de los políticos peruanos que conforman la
primera línea de mando, motivaciones que
no tienen que ver con el interés general.
Son representantes públicos que han dejado
muy claro que solo se representan a sí mismos.
Algo que también podemos ver con la corrupción
galopante que parece afectar a la política
peruana.
Y, ojo, que no hablamos del típico problema
que nos podemos encontrar en cualquier país
de un político que pone la mano para nada.
(Todos los indicadores apuntan a que la corrupción
en las instituciones peruanas es algo común.
Las encuestas apuntan a que el 36% de los
peruanos consideran a la corrupción como
el problema más importante. El 26,3% señalan
haberla sufrido personalmente y más del 75%
de todos los ciudadanos peruanos consideran
que la corrupción es habitual entre funcionarios
y políticos.
De hecho, según Transparencia Internacional
Perú ha pasado de ser el 44 país menos corrupto
del mundo en el año 2000, en los últimos
años su posición ha oscilado entre los puestos
106 y 94.)
Para colmo, todo este tipo de juegos políticos
desvía la atención hacia temas que en nada
promueven la prosperidad del Perú.
Y eso, eso tiene consecuencias.
(EL TARJETAZO Y EL ESTADO PASIVO)
Amigos, amigas, durante los últimos 20 años el Perú ha registrado una importante mejora económica que, entre otras, ha engordado
los ingresos del estado.  Un estado que no ha dejado de crecer en empleados públicos en muchos casos mediante lo que se conoce como el tarjetazo.
Esto es, colocar a familiares, amigos y compinches
de todo tipo a cobrar del estado.
Y lo que es peor, todo este incremento de
empleados públicos no se ha traducido en
una mejora real del funcionamiento del estado.
Los grandes problemas de hace 10 años siguen
siendo básicamente los mismos que hoy. Y
para colmo durante este tiempo lo que sí
ha crecido es la burocracia.
Ahora bien, ¿de qué problemas hablamos exactamente?
Pues fijaos.
(A pesar de tener una salud financiera envidiable,
la escasez de infraestructuras en el país
es tan acusada que según el foro económico
mundial, la calidad de las mismas solo se
encuentra por encima de las de Venezuela,
Bolivia y Paraguay. Hablamos de un gap que
algunos cálculos recientes sitúan en unos
300 mil millones de dólares, lo que por supuesto
afecta a la actividad económica.)
Y, podéis creerme, cualquiera que haya estado
en Perú sabe perfectamente de qué estamos
hablando.
Luego, el sector financiero está tan poco
desarrollado y tan cerrado a la competencia,
que los peruanos tienen más dificultades
para acceder a la financiación y sufren tipos
mucho más altos, lo que por supuesto perjudica
la inversión. Para que os hagáis una idea
los pequeños préstamos con tipos del 20,
el 30 o incluso el 40% no son algo extraño.
Y de hecho, lo que se conoce como el Spread
bancario, esto es el margen de los bancos
es de más del 14% frente a poco más del
3% en los países de la OCDE. Para colmo apenas
el 7% de las empresas logra acceder a financiación
bancaria.
De la misma forma, los mercados de capitales
están infradesarrollados, la Bolsa de Lima
es una broma y el sistema de pensiones lleva
en punto muerto y necesitado de reformas desde
hace ya muchísimos años.
Por ejemplo, el sistema privado de pensiones,
similar al modelo de Chile apenas cubre al
20% de los peruanos en edad de trabajar. Además
es un modelo cerrado a la competencia con
comisiones muy altas que devoran la rentabilidad
de los partícipes.
Y respecto al sistema público, casi mejor
no hablemos. La pensión media mensual es
de poco más de 150 dólares al mes. Y eso
quien tiene la suerte de recibirla, porque
entre otras cosas hay que trabajar más de
20 años.
(En total el sistema privado y el sistema
público de pensiones apenas cubren al 30%
de los peruanos mayores de 65 años. El resto
o reciben algún subsidio pequeño del programa
Pensión 65 o directamente no reciben nada,
que es exactamente lo que ocurre con más
del 40% de los mayores.)
Luego las empresas públicas son un desastre.
Apenas son capaces de invertir, muchas se
han convertido en nidos de corrupción, en
algunas los puestos de trabajo son hereditarios
por acuerdo sindical y desde luego no son
rentables.
PetroPerú por ejemplo acumula pérdidas de
más de 3.000 millones de dólares durante
la última década.
[Una petrolera perdiendo dinero de forma sostenida
en el tiempo. Desde luego cuando ves estas
cosas sabés que estás hablando de Latinoamérica]
Y aún podríamos seguir:
(La educación es paupérrima, los planes
urbanísticos están tan desfasados que desde
el 2001 más del 90% de las expansiones urbanas
se han llevada a cabo de forma irregular cuando
no abiertamente ilegal.
En el campo, que genera más del 30% de todos
los empleos del país, la mayoría se mantiene
en condiciones de subsistencia. Sin apoyo
en formación, mecanización o desarrollo
de cooperativas y asociaciones.)
Y claro, así pues no se puede.
Es algo que por cierto, favorece que como
alternativa se opte por plantaciones de coca.
Y,ojo que Perú es el segundo mayor productor
de cocaína del mundo.
(Cultivos de coca en Perú se expanden a 72,000
hectáreas, según la Casa Blanca Perú es
por detrás Colombia el segundo productor
mundial de cocaína. Gestión)
Es un suma y sigue constante.
Pero, ¿sabéis qué? Todas estas cosas para
los políticos peruanos parecen secundarias.
Pero claro, son cosas que terminan teniendo
consecuencias sociales y económicas.
(Por ejemplo, se calcula que hay entre 25.000
y 50.000 millones de dólares en proyectos
mineros detenidos ante el rechazo social simple
y llanamente porque el gobierno no ha tenido
el liderazgo de buscar fórmulas que favorezcan
a las comunidades locales. Hablamos de una
fuente de riqueza potencialmente enorme que
por ejemplo, en países donde las cosas se
hacen bien como Australia, han propiciado
una enorme prosperidad general.)
Y bueno la mala prensa de la minería es comprensible.
En el pasado se permitieron muchos abusos
a cambio de bueno..., ¿recordáis lo que
decíamos de las coimas en el país?
El caso es que en el país no hay impulso
a la innovación, la política de atracción
de inversiones es insuficiente, no hay desarrollo
de zonas estratégicas o polos de actividad.
El gobierno peruano tiene unas finanzas saneadas
pero parece no saber hacer nada más. Por
así decirlo, avanza con una especie de piloto
automático que ya es claramente insuficiente
para impulsar el desarrollo pero que permite
que muchos sectores estén en manos de una
élite que se protege de la competencia.
Amigos, en entornos corruptos y en los que
solo cuenta la supervivencia política, la
selección de líderes y profesionales no
se realiza en base a la meritocracia sino
sobre todo a la lealtad.
Eso provoca que cada vez los cuadros de gestión
tengan peor nivel. Lo que a su vez alimenta
la falta de capacidad para tomar medidas y
la falta de honestidad y transparencia.
El mayor problema del Perú no es Pedro Castillo.
El mayor problema del Perú es lo que ha conducido
a un político como Castillo a ganar las elecciones.
Y llegados a este punto, la pregunta es, ¿Sera
Castillo un peligro para el Perú? Desde luego
no pinta bien, aunque puede que al final el
agua no llegue al río. No tiene mayoría
parlamentaria y no es descabellado que se
parezca más a Humala que a personajes como
Hugo Chavez.
("No habrá expropiaciones, no habrá estatizaciones,
no le vamos a quitar su propiedad ni ahorros
a nadie. Queremos una economía popular con
mercados. La independencia del Banco Central
será respetada porque ha hecho una buena
labor de mantener la inflación baja. No estamos
en la idea bolivariana, lo queremos desmentir".
Pedro Francke, asesor económico de Pedro
Castillo)
En cualquier caso, que mensajes como el suyo
dominen la política peruana no son un buen
augurio. Pero no nos engañemos. El problema
ya estaba en casa y no es otro que los políticos
que han convertido las instituciones peruanas
en su parque de atracciones particular.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti.
¿Qué futuro crees que le espera al Perú
bajo el mando de Castillo?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvides darle a like y suscribirte
a visualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.